ship to address order now usually ships
and four to six weeks I can make my own
towels in four to six weeks mayor you
have a visitor
not now I'm having problems but mayor
it's a Jeff Bezos
founder and CEO of Amazon Jeff Bezos
yeah okay okay let him in right on
through here mr. BAE's us mr. Bezos how
great to see you again
how have you been I wish I was doing
better
please man have a seat oh thank you
[Music]
I guess you're here because of the
strike we had a deal here you told me
this town would be the perfect place for
one of our fulfillment centers and it
has been and it gave so many people jobs
and I'm not really sure why everyone is
so disgruntled dissatisfied and amused
would you like to know why Amazon is so
successful because the customer is all
that matters now orders are going
unfulfilled all over the state of
Colorado that an exhaustive very bad it
makes you look very bad perhaps you
should no longer be a prime member
please I'm trying to get everyone back
to work I'm gonna do everything that I
can then we have an understanding
goodbye man if everyone stays
unfulfilled it will be you
[Music]